hey it's evan i got a great question
from one of my youtube viewers who is
asking about evernote and how to use it
uh with other apps so evernote is great
in that it can easily connect with a
whole bunch of different web tools and
apps i don't use it too heavily but i
wanted to show you what i do use it for
and hopefully that gives you some advice
for your your life and your business too
so this is my evernote desktop version
and mostly i use evernote to to record
things and then be able to have it on
any device that i need so most of my
evernote
lists are are just that their list their
ideas so this for example is food this
is something i need to buy for the for
my breakfast from the office for from my
home
and so when i'm at the store i might i
might type this up on my computer and
then i'm at the store and i can load it
up on my phone and i know exactly what i
need to get
sometimes i'll use it in conjunction
with my mobile device if i'm reading
something this is a pdf from tim
ferriss's book uh the four-hour chef
that's talking about cooking and what i
did was i took a screenshot of it
and
within my mobile device once you take a
picture of something or screenshot you
can save it to evernote and so i did
that and now i have this you know kind
of
point form quick overview of his
thoughts on cooking that i can
load up any time when it's on every
device i have because it's within
evernote so
i'll just quickly click the share option
and then go to evernote after i take the
picture
here's another one
again from the four hour chef
just took a screenshot i like the page
so easy to remember instead of trying to
write everything down take a screenshot
of my screen and save it to evernote
if i go to
maybe my business stuff for you guys to
have a quick look again i'll use it for
different you know mostly notes again
but if i find for example a magazine
article that i want to take a picture of
you know i want to save this information
so this is about
avoiding the tax man this is a article
in a magazine i wanted to save i didn't
want to save the whole magazine and i
wanted to have again the information
available wherever i needed it to be so
i took a picture with my phone and this
is about setting up different structures
so that you're not paying a lot of taxes
um this is for the canadian government
for those of you guys who are from
canada watching this
and again once i take the picture on my
phone i have the option to share it i
just pick business notes and now i have
this forever in whatever device i'm on
i'll use it to take screenshots so with
my web browser
this is a my process for when i create
my webinars for example i'll take a
screenshot of my google plus page and so
it'll show up here
easy to copy and paste the screenshot in
and then i'll also use the web clipper
so this is an example of an article that
i read i think it was in the new york
times
about what big companies can get from
helping small companies and it was a
great article that i wanted to save have
access to whenever i needed it and so
you can use the web
clipper tool that evernote gives you and
again automatically saves it to your
folder i can pull it up on any device
easy to search
and so that's how i
use
evernote so i don't integrate it with
too many apps but most apps that are out
there have some kind of option to save
to evernote and so if you ever need to
save anything if you ever need to have
anything that has quick access to it
again in the future
or if you want to ever be able to search
something that you've seen before then a
great way to share it is to one of your
evernote folders and then the
information will always be there waiting
for you so here are a whole bunch of my
if i go to my notebooks
this is for the book i'm writing this is
my business this is
personal stuff this is for one of the
investments i've made into a salsa
dancing company
receipts that have all the scanned
receipts that i've i've put in
family receipts guitar music doesn't
have anything there yet memories things
i wanted to save these are old pictures
clippings uh things that i you know turn
into digital instead of storing actual
pictures recipes salsa related to
dancing self-tracking experiments i'm
running running on myself that i want to
see the data
places to check out in toronto which is
my local city
so if i read an article or a blog post
on some new store that's opened up in
toronto i want to check out i can save
it here and then i can pull it up on my
phone and go visit the place
and vacation related notes i'll save
pictures and maps and i actually just
came back from a vacation from uh in
europe and here's an example of how i
used it and brought stuff in
so i was looking to go salsa dancing in
barcelona and i found three different
salsa clubs and again i was just
clipping tools clipping sites online
and this one was mojito house i took a
clip of their website the days that
they're open the times and i can scroll
down and i could see a map
of where they were
and now it's staying somewhere here so
you can see how far it is to get there
here's another one again description map
another one
description and a map and so i'll save
all this information so that when i'm
actually on the ground in barcelona i
don't have data access without paying
crazy roman fees i have all this
information down i know when they're
open i know information about the
location and i can pull up their map and
find out where i am and and get there
and i'll do this often for any
information i need offline it's great
for when you're traveling this was my
hotel
this is uh directions to a place in new
york that i was going to
how to get there from my hotel walk in
direction so i love using this for
travel and again this is just using
their web clipper tool so again any
information you need to save or search
or have future reference to there's
there's usually a tool that you can
connect evernote to and i find it's a
great way to keep track of your data
manage your to-do list and help you
organize all your information so i hope
you guys like this video found it
helpful i'm i'm a big believer in
evernote and i'm using it more and more
for my my personal life and for my
business to keep track of everything
if you guys like the video please give
it a thumbs up below and if you have
questions about how to use evernote for
your business please leave it in the
comments below and i will do my best to
create a video response for you
just like i just made for the other
reader so thank you guys and i'll see
you soon